new 8 news now is continuing to examine
where covid 19 is spreading
nursing homes is one area the itunes
vanessa murphy live with more
on which facilities are at the very top
of the list vanessa
brian close to 900 patients and
residents
inside nursing homes in clark county
alone have tested positive for covid19
since the start of the pandemic
more than 200 have died now
some facilities haven't had many cases
but according to the state
other facilities have had outbreaks now
the eye team examined the numbers for
every nursing home in clark county and
here are the facilities with the highest
covet 19 numbers
the heights of summerlin with a total of
167 cases
that includes both patients and staff 8
news now has reported on this facility
before
at least 30 patients died from the virus
there and more than
60 percent of their resident population
contracted covet 19.
del mar gardens in henderson has had 133
confirmed cases
28 patients and one staff member died
from the virus
lake mead health and rehabilitation in
henderson
has had 177 confirmed cases
19 patients there died of the virus as
well as
to staff members again that is all
according
to data from the state i reached out to
all three places to get a comment
a response a statement something to find
out what they are doing about covid19 i
did not hear back
in time for this report reporting live
vanessa murphy 8 news now